le métro nouveaux lieux de vaccination
pour les new yorkais depuis ce mercredi
la gare de grand central est devenu un
nouveau centre d'accueil pour la
campagne américaine
ouvert à tous ce dispositif a pour but
de vacciner rapidement avec le sérum de
johnson & johnson et pour les passants
encore hésitants impasse de métro d'une
semaine est offert à tous les néo
vacciner c'est plus pratique parce que
c'est un endroit sans rendez vous avant
il n'y avait pas de lieu comme ça il
fallait prendre rendez vous et nous
avons essayé mais on n'y arrivait pas
tout était complet alors je me suis dit
que j'allais attendre qu'ils aient une
place libre pour recevoir mon vaccin
c'était sur mon trajet de métro et c'est
gratuit et sans rendez vous alors je me
suis dit vous savez quoi je devrais
juste m'arrêter le faire pour encourager
la vaccination les initiatives se
multiplient aux etats-unis après le
bonus d'epargne pour les 16-35 ans
virginie occidentale ou encore les 100
dollars offerts dans le maryland
l'état de l'ohio a annoncé qu'une
loterie allait être organisée pour toute
personne ayant reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin un gagnant sera annoncé chaque
mercredi pendant cinq semaines à partir
du 26 mai récompenses à la clé un
million de dollars je sais que certains
peuvent dire de wine tu es fou votre
idée de projet un million de dollars est
un gaspillage d'argent mais vraiment le
vrai gaspillage à ce stade de la
pandémie alors que le vaccin est
facilement disponible pour tout ce
qu'ils veulent est une vie perdue à
cause du coït 19 ce mercredi l agence
américaine des médicaments a autorisé
l'injection du vaccin
feiler bio n tech aux adolescents entre
12 et 15 ans à ce jour plus de 153
millions d'américains ont reçu au moins
une dose de sérum anti corrida soit plus
de 45% de la population